زلزاله تركيا اربك المشهد السياسي في
البلاد مع اقتراب الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه في مايو المقبل الاثنين
الماضي كان من المفترض ان تتفق فيه
المعارضه السياسيه باطيافها على مرشح موحد
لها ليقف في مواجهه الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان الا ان الزلزال اجل هذا الاجتماع
مصادر في الحزب الحاكم والمعارضه بدات
الترويج عن انباء ان الرئيس اردوغان سيؤجل
الانتخابات في اعقاب الكارثه التي شهدتها
تركيا الاسبوع الماضي صحيفه احوال التركيه
قالت ان المعارضه ستحاول الاستفاده من
الغضب الشعبي بسبب الدمار الذي لحق بتركيا
جراء الزلزال دون الظهور بصوره السعيد
للحصول على مكاسب سياسيه من الماسد حتى
الان يعتبر كمالك لتشدار اوغلو هو ابرز
المرشحين وهو رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري
طبعا سيواجه اردوغ لان المعارضه منقسمه
لازلت على اسم المرشح ويعتبر ويعتبر خبراء
فعليا ان انتخابات مايو باتت غير وارده
لكنها قد تجرى في يونيو وهو اخر موعد
لاجراءها وفق الدستور اما اذا اقتضى الامر
تاجيا لموعد ابعد فسيكون على اردوغان
الحصول على غالبيه الثلوثين في البرلمان
وهو رقم ليس بجعبه الرئيس وحلفائه ما يعني
انه سيلجا الى المعارضه للموافقه على
تاجيل الانتخابات
[موسيقى]